dieser bahnübergang in kirchzarten in
baden württemberg wurde komplett
umgebaut schranken ampeln und
andreaskreuze alles brandneu
doch diese neue technik schlummert noch
im dornröschenschlaf jedes mal wenn sich
ein zug nähert müssen deshalb zwei
bahnmitarbeiter sogar im dichten
schneetreiben wie diese woche im
handbetrieb die kreuzung mit rot weißen
bändern sichern seit monaten in der
heutigen zeit ins umland wo alles da ist
und technik da sein sollte finde ich
einfach ein no go das sowas so lange
dauert bis da mal die ampel in betrieb
ist ich finde die lachnummer lächerlich
der jumbo vor was das koste sind die
zwei man müsse doch bezahlt im
vergangenen jahr wird der bahnübergang
komplett saniert laut bahn kostet so
eine neue schrankenanlage mindestens
500.000 euro
das kernstück ist dieser radler scanner
er soll kontrollieren ob der übergang
tatsächlich frei ist und bei einem
rückstau den zugverkehr automatisch
stoppen
seit dezember rollen hier wieder die
züge aber der bahnübergang in
kirchzarten muss noch immer per hand
gesichert werden auch nach vier monaten
schafft dass die bahn nicht die teuren
gerätschaften ans laufen zu bringen
warum weiß keiner und die bahn will es
nicht verraten
auch der kirchzartener bürgermeister ist
ratlos also über die situation erfahren
wir als gemeinde natürlich auch so
manches unverständnis oder auch
schmunzeln
es war auch an fasnacht der running gag
bei uns im dorf
aber natürlich sind wir zunächst mal
voraus gemeinde dass der bahnübergang
überhaupt in betrieb ist bei der
deutschen bahn kann man die aufregung
überhaupt nicht verstehen schriftlich
heißt es sicherheit hat bei der bahn
oberste priorität
deshalb sichern wir eine neue technik in
der anfangsphase zusätzlich mit
bahnübergangs posten ab nun von
zusätzlich kann in kirchzarten keine
rede sein
die schranken sind gut verpackt bewegen
sich keinen millimeter und die ampeln
sind verhüllt sicher tun hier nur die
jungs nieren wetterfesten anzügen
als kurier finde ich das weil es das
erinnert mich an den handbetrieb
vielleicht im eisenbahnverkehr vor 100
jahren in der arbeitsplatzbeschaffung
maß nach wird von der aparten keine
ahnung wo die traurig ist dass wir die
situation kann man immer lacht sie sich
seit vier monate hin und ich bin
überzeugt das geht noch vier monate
wenn es überhaupt erreicht laut bahn
soll das problem in absehbarer zeit
behoben sein
zumal vier monate verspätung sogar für
bayern verhältnisse ziemlich lang sind